senator joe manchin says it's time to
hit pause on joe biden's spending plans
as biden's approval ratings creator the
afghanistan debacle has destroyed
biden's credibility and the biden
economy is flailing i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the ven shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected
expressvpn.com we'll get to all the news
in just one moment first this is your
reminder that your data is indeed
vulnerable to people who are not you
online and you're constantly using the
online world right you're making
payments or you're sending emails well
all of that data is accessible by people
who are not you whether we're talking
about your isp or whether we're talking
about hackers every time you connect to
an unencrypted network in cafes hotels
airports etc your online data is not
secured any hacker on the same network
can gain access to and steal your
personal data passwords financial
details you name it and today it doesn't
take advanced technical knowledge to
hack somebody just some cheap hardware
as needed a smart 12 year old could do
it that's why i recommend expressvpn
expressvpn creates that secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so that hackers can't steal
your sensitive data not only is it
incredibly secure it is also super easy
to use just fire up the app click one
button to get protected expressvpn works
on phones laptops tablets and all your
devices so you can stay secure on the go
secure your online data today by
visiting
expressvpn.com that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s vpn
dot com slash ben you get an extra three
months for free against expressvpn.com
ben already well we are very early on in
the joe biden presidency and it seems
like this thing could be theoretically
kind of over already it is pretty
obvious that next year republicans have
a solid leg up when it comes to the
possibility of taking the house it now
looks as though they have a very solid
shot of taking the senate if polls are
to be believed from places like new
hampshire where john sununu is now up
something like seven or eight points on
his democratic opponent
if republicans take back congress joe
biden effectively gets nothing done for
the next couple of years which means
he's a very short window of time to ram
things through here is the problem in
order for him to ram things through he
needs complete solidarity particularly
in the senate where he has a 50-50 split
with the republicans with kamala harris
his vice president breaking the tie
again that wouldn't have happened if
donald trump had not intervened in the
georgia senate races and talked all
about how georgia's voting system was a
complete waste of time and all of this
but put that
be
be that as it may put that aside the
bottom line here is that he still has a
very very
narrow pathway to getting things done in
the united states senate and that
requires solidarity among democrats in
order to cudgel people like kirsten
cinema and joe manchin into doing what
joe biden wants
he really needs to have some coattails
joe biden himself needs to have
coattails because here's the thing when
it comes to things like budget
reconciliation you can do this thing
with 50 votes pretty much everything
else you require 60 manchin and cinema
who are both from red states cinema you
might say is from a purple state but the
one of the red estates in the country is
west virginia
neither of them are going to break the
filibuster they've made this very clear
over and over and over no matter how
many times the activist media asks them
about it so that means that basically
everything has to get done through
budget reconciliation well the giant
omnibus packages that are being pushed
by joe biden are not on their face
particularly pleasant for either of
those senators for either cinema or
mansion they're not popular in arizona
they're not popular in west virginia and
remember senators are not answerable to
the quote unquote national polling they
are answerable specifically to the
people who are in their own states
so the chances are that mansion and
cinema are not going to be super happy
with these giant policy proposals which
means the only reason why they would do
what joe biden wants is if they believe
that joe biden's coattails are strong
enough to carry them through even in red
purple states that he's overwhelmingly
popular and therefore they will be able
to go back to their voters and say we
did all of these things because joe
biden told us to do all of these things
and therefore it is good that we did all
of these things if joe biden's
popularity craters therefore
his chances of being able to ram through
his agenda
completely fall apart if he had a
broader majority maybe his approval
ratings wouldn't matter so much but his
approval ratings matter an awful lot
especially because waiting in the wings
and everybody knows this is kamala
harris who's a deeply unpopular
politician so if you're joe manchin
charting your political future and
thinking to yourself am i still here in
four or five years do i get re-elected
you're gonna hit your wagon to joe biden
and kamal harris or are you gonna chart
your own course same thing for kristen
cinema over in arizona she's pretty good
approval ratings the reason she has
pretty good approval ratings is because
she's seen as a sort of democratic
version of john mccain sort of a
maverick character willing to buck her
own party and say tough things to the
people inside her own party about for
example the filibuster or about too much
spending
so this now puts enormous power in the
hands of joe manchin and that power only
grows when joe biden is not good at his
job so that means it matters an awful
lot whether joe biden is liked or
whether he is disliked on the national
stage and that's why it matters that his
poll numbers have been absolutely
cratering now they're cratering for
basically one specific reason and then
one general reason so the specific
reason is because of afghanistan
the general reason is because joe biden
is a house plant so he was elected
because he was a house plant right but
he was a house plant who's supposed to
provide stability the thing about house
plans is that they are barely alive they
cover the water stain and they don't
move around a lot you don't have to
worry about the house plant you leave
the house for the for work in the
morning you come back the house plants
in exactly the same place maybe it's
grown a little bit that's pretty much it
but joe biden elected as a house plant
is actually turning out to be the plant
from a little shop of horrors right he's
eating everything else he's in terms of
policy he's very much alive even though
in terms of sentience he is not and so
if you voted for joe biden or if you are
somebody in the middle who's kind of
warm to joe biden you're kind of getting
the worst of both worlds you're getting
the non-sentient non-charismatic
president but he's not like obama in any
of the areas of charisma or magnetism or
personal draw and you're getting the
radical policy of barack obama except on
steroids because actually joe biden's
policies are way more radical than
barack obama's were at this point even
in his presidency and obama was really
radical on policy this early on in his
presidency
and so every time joe biden now appears
and seems to be doddering his way
through a press conference it hurts him
rather than helping him if he were a
moderate and he were daughtering his way
through people would be willing to say
that that's kind of a feature not a bug
all right he's daughtering but the
reason he's daughtering is because we
elected somebody to daughter the whole
point is we wanted somebody who moved
slowly incrementally somebody who is not
going to be threatening but if he's
threatening and also daughtering now it
just seems like things are spinning out
of control and so every press conference
that he has where he seems incapable of
holding it together is a serious problem
for him that's why the afghanistan
debacle made so clear that he is is just
not in control right even when he makes
a call those calls are so incapable
of meeting with any sort of good policy
that this seems like an administration
where the brakes have been taken off and
you literally have an octogenarian in
charge of the car driving directly at a
crowd
and everybody's kind of freaking out
about that which means that if you're a
moderate on the fence if you're joe by a
joe manchin or if your christian cinema
you're like i don't want to be in this
cloud in this car the future of this car
is not good
okay so let's go to the the doddering of
joe biden and then we'll get to the
policy of joe biden so when it comes to
the daughtering of joe biden he um he
just continues to lie and around
it really is not good for him all of
these things add up like the way that
that people make decisions about
politicians typically is that over and
over and over their preconceived notions
about those politicians are either
rejected or reinforced joe biden every
day is reinforcing the fact that he is
not with us that he is not with us
that his policies are radical and he's
not in control that this is a car
careening out of control no brakes
octogenarian at the wheel who should
have had his license revoked at least
five years ago
here was joe biden yesterday he was
doing a a
kind of meet and greet
with a with a bunch of ju so-called
jewish leaders i say so-called because a
lot of the jewish leaders that he was
meeting with aren't particularly jewish
in any sort of
religious sense and they kind of lead
reconstructionist synagogues that don't
reflect any of the principles of the
torah they're not particularly
interested in jewish philosophy but put
that aside joe biden is speaking to them
and he starts just telling lies about
visiting the tree of life synagogue it
turns out that he did not the tree of
life synagogue of course was the site of
the white supremacist shooting a couple
of years ago and uh he said he visited
he he absolutely did not he's just
making things up i remember
spending time
at the you know uh
go going to uh
the you know the tree of life synagogue
speaking with them
just it's just as amazing these things
are happening
happening in america
okay and then he started daughtering
through a story about his daughter's
wedding he couldn't remember what was
going on it's very awkward i mean it's
your grandpa is wandering off script
no it's it's
reminiscent i think it's a mitch hedberg
joke or a jack handy joke you know that
when when i go i want to go like my
grandfather did peacefully in his sleep
not like the passengers in his car
screaming
that's that's the democratic party at
this point right here here's joe biden
again kind of wandering off script into
the cornfield
my daughter
married a jewish young man
and i you know dream of every
every every
catholic father that she married a
jewish doctor
but uh all kind of aside he did is a
great surgeon and they played and i'm my
mind's going blank now what's the song
that is played where everybody is on the
chair everybody you know
what i can't remember it anyway
and that's the song was played
so you know i don't know what the hell
is going on here
inspiring stuff there from the president
of the united states very very very
inspiring stuff and then he added on top
of this he says you know he starts
talking about never again
now this is where you move from the
senile to the
rather unforgivable here's joe biden
talking about never again which of
course is verbiage that is used
surrounding the holocaust that we as the
world will never allow this sort of
stuff to happen again
i have some questions for joe biden
about this particular perspective coming
out of his face his daughtering old
collapsing face here's the president of
the united states
i guess the point i want to make is that
it just shows that
if we walk away from never again
it's going to happen again
it can't happen again
and so
i guess the point i'm making is that the
attack in pittsburgh those attacks
all anti-semitic attacks aren't just a
strike against the jewish community
they're a strike against the soul of our
nation
okay i'm just going to point out when he
says we cancel and never again to happen
this is the same president who is
currently attempting to deal with the
genocidal iranian regime to allow them a
pathway to nuclear weapons
this is the same president of the united
states who is currently talking about
opening a palestinian consulate in
jerusalem reopening the wounds of a
process that has completely failed and
incentivizing terror attacks in the
region against jews
this is the same president of the united
states who on another front you want to
talk about never again just abandon 38
million people to today's nazis the
taliban who are literally gonna go
around just murdering everybody they
don't like this is already happening in
afghanistan right now this is the same
president who's been making kind
overtures to china which has become
increasingly aggressive meanwhile
holding in shenzhen one million uyghur
muslims in concentration camps so when
this guy says i'm anti-uh you know never
again means something me no it doesn't
it absolutely 100 is not it's a bunch of
words that he thinks he has to say in
front of you and here's the thing he has
no credibility on these issues he just
doesn't
his own administration has completely
afghanistan is a perfect case in point
he literally just said we're for human
rights when we have to say thing about
it say things about it but when we
actually have to you know do something
basic like leaving 2 500 troops there
with no no actual combat casualties in a
support role then i won't do that he is
so unwilling to stand up for human
rights i mean don't don't talk the
language of human rights if you are
literally unwilling to make even the
most minute sacrifices on behalf of
human rights
and not just human rights by the way
american interests in afghanistan but as
long as he's going to be saying never
again
you know there's a lot there's in the
jewish community there's been talk for
decades about why it was that the allies
didn't bomb the rail lines uh during the
holocaust why didn't they but why didn't
the allies send a few planes and just
bomb the rail lines that were connecting
various cities to the concentration
camps and the defense has always been it
was the middle of a war you have to use
those bombs where they are best utilized
namely against nazi troops in more
strategically necessary areas that's an
open argument historically speaking
okay but here we are not even talking
about even that kind of sacrifice we are
talking about
the united states of america leaving in
place
people who were already there doing the
things they were already doing to
prevent people from being shot in the
face for walking in the street without a
veil
and joe biden wasn't even willing to do
that
so no i'm not particularly interested in
hearing about never again from this
doofus
it's just
his credibility is shocked it's shocked
speaking of afghanistan
the administration just has no defense
for itself at this point
in ned price for example the state
department spokesperson he was freely
admitted yesterday that the united
states left several hundred us funded
journalists in afghanistan
how many of those usa gm employees were
there or contractors rather and how many
uh family members out of
uh
so i don't have a a firm uh figure uh
with me i uh it has been reported
publicly that there are several hundred
uh involved involved in that group
okay also the ap's matt lee who's pretty
good foreign policy reporter he also
grill price said how many green card
holders are stuck over there you just
don't care about those people anymore
apparently
you must have some estimate of lprs who
are who are still there who want who
want to get out and if you don't why not
well matt uh we let me let me first
start with this issue of the the 100 to
200 i'm just asking about green card
holders was there a decision made
at some point
to forget about those people and only
allow
us passport holders
in and onto that in into the airport
through your checkpoints not the file
eventually through your checkpoints and
onto
and on to planes because
a lot of them feel like they frankly got
screwed here and that they were lied to
and of course they were screwed and they
were lied to there are parades by the
way of taliban fighters who are walking
around uh in suicide vests so these are
our new allies over in the middle east
one reporter slammed the pentagon's john
kirby who again has become the baghdad
bob of this particular operation saying
you know you keep saying this is a
strategic success i'm wondering exactly
how
how can the department of defense go
before the american people
those military service members and those
veterans and say that the mission was
accomplished when people were left
behind
i think trace we've been very clear that
that we don't believe
the effort has concluded
the military mission
of evacuation is over we know there are
people that didn't make it out american
citizens as well as special immigrant
visa applicants and we are
and the us government
is going to continue to look for ways to
try to help them find safe passage out
of the country
[Music]
now the media predictably are beginning
to spin on behalf of the biden
administration throughout all of this
there's an entire piece in the new york
times state talking about how the
taliban are going to be pragmatic
they're going to be awesome according to
the new york times max fisher as taliban
commanders exchange their guns for the
reigns of power some 38 million afghans
can do little but hold their breath and
wait to see how their latest conquerors
will rule that uncertainty also palpable
in foreign capitals from washington to
beijing is compounded by the deep
contradiction between the group's record
of extremism and brutality during its
prior reign from 1996 to 2000 and its
promises of moderation today there's no
uncertainty they're lying they're not
going to be moderate they're going to do
exactly what they want to do by the way
beijing has already said they're going
to recognize the taliban regime
but says max fisher the taliban are
depending on how to take one can
depending on how one counts something
like the sixth or seventh rebel group to
take over a country in the modern era
while no two are exactly alike certain
patterns have emerged and how rebels
rule some learn to govern effectively
even to modernize others collapsing
chaos a renewed war some grow crueler in
power lashing out at their subjects in
fear and insecurity others moderate the
mostly in search of legitimacy and
foreign aid but all seem to share a few
traits a tightly bureaucratic
authoritarianism albeit sometimes
allowing a degree of political opening a
focus on controlling or coercing
elements of society seen as tied to the
old order and a quest for foreign
support and recognition as they strain
to overcome the pariah status that tends
to greet militants who shoot their way
into power
so we can we can expect them that
probably they're going to be you know
eventually they're going to turn into
like regular ruling people seeking
pragmatic
relations with the rest of or
alternatively they are going to continue
being the bunch of drug running which is
how they supported themselves from 96 to
2001 drug running beijing supported
terror group that they've always been
but gotta swing that gotta swing that
support back behind biden by the way the
fact checkers are doing yeoman's work on
this it's amazing like if you just wanna
see what the biden administration
assigned fact checkers are doing today
check the right hand side of the twitter
feed
the twitter feed every single day has
some sort of fact check targeting a
minor
fact that was
put out there that was that was wrong
while ignoring the far broader narrative
so there'll be a fact check about how
you know there's a helicopter and it was
flying a guy around you remember the
taliban wearing a harness and it looked
like maybe a guy was hanging from
underneath and people mentioned this
that was not true that was not true of
course the idea there is this is a very
important fact check super important
we're not going to fact check the
president of the united states saying he
always had a plan for this we're not
going to fact check the president of the
united states saying no one expected
that this thing was going to collapse as
fast as it was you're not going to fact
check the president of the united states
when he says this is historic success
like none of those things are worthy of
a fact check but it is worth a fact
track that the person hanging from
underneath the helicopter this time was
not the body of an enemy it was just a
taliban fighter which means now it's
good that they have our blackhawk
helicopters obviously the other fact
check that made the rounds yesterday is
the media attempting to defend joe biden
for checking his watch repeatedly at the
at the ceremony for the fallen it's over
air force base
okay the the usa today actually had to
change its own claim they actually
claimed it was outright false that joe
biden checked his watch during the
ceremony
originally they claimed it was outright
false then it turns out there were
multiple gold star family members who
said no joe biden kept checking his
watch over and over and over i checked
it 5 10 13 times during the actual
ceremony honoring the fallen
so what did usa today do did they revise
their fact check
they only changed it to missing context
i'm not kidding you they didn't say now
that it's true that joe biden was
checking his watch they literally
changed it to missing context here is
their correction
this story was updated september 2nd to
note that biden checked his watch
multiple times at the dignified transfer
event including during the ceremony
itself the rating on this claim has been
changed from partly false to missing
context
i was missing context you see
it's amazing they'll never just say joe
biden checked his watch by the way the
white house didn't even deny he checked
his watch jen's hockey was asked about
it she avoided the question but the
media are in full spin mode for biden
because this has been very very damaging
for him don lemon who can always be
counted on to defend the worst members
of the democratic administration he said
you know biden's getting beat up too
much on afghanistan man it's not that
big a deal i mean it's not like he's
unvaccinated or something
you know i think people should stop
beating up on the administration
so much
because no matter how it ended everyone
wasn't going to be happy with the way it
ended so
if there's any
silver lining in this it's going to be
what happens going forward you can't
change the past you can't bring those
lives back as awful as that is and so
you know i just think that sometimes i
think the administration is getting
beaten up on this a little bit too much
because there's a lot of blame to go
around from four different presidents
and who actually didn't have the guts to
get us out of afghanistan because they
were afraid of this moment and what an
exit might look like
man that guy is just journalism being
everywhere all over the biden
administration all over their head i
mean it's just wild the levels of
journalism that are going on right now
they're from from don lemon it's really
really well done aoc by the way also
defending the administration so when aoc
is defending biden you know things have
gone wildly wrong for the administration
i don't know
what the measure
or expectation is
of what a quote unquote successful
withdrawal is
but i
hope people understand
that this is what war looks like
it is not
neat
and it is not pretty it is violent
it is
brutal
and
and we're out here
and we're out here expecting like this
is supposed to be a cakewalk i mean
this this is war
okay this is the same person who will
condemn
the israeli government every time a
civilian is killed when you have
terrorists hiding behind civilians this
is the same person who will make light
of riots in american cities but you know
war is war man if we gotta leave a bunch
of americans behind afghanistan that's
what we'll do this is famed women's
rights advocate aoc who basically is
just like you know man okay so we pulled
out there are 19 million women most of
whom are under the age of 25 living in
living in afghanistan and they're just
gonna be subjected to vicious rape
repeatedly but you know it was rough it
was rough so the defenses are not
working and herein lies the problem for
job i'll get to that in just one moment
first
we are proud that gcu grand canyon
university is a supporter of the ben
shapiro show okay as you know i am very
critical of a lot of institutions of
higher learning i think they don't teach
values i don't think they teach things
that are worthwhile not so at grand
canyon university it's an affordable
christian university one of the largest
fastest growing universities in the
country located in sunny phoenix arizona
gcu is ranked top 20 for best college
campuses in america it offers over 275
engaging academic programs with over 240
online by the way it's a beautiful place
to be i visited a couple of years ago it
the students are wonderful it's really
great gcu integrates the free market
system with the welcoming christian
worldview perspective into its academic
programs so you can put your faith into
action and help transform communities in
2020 gcu students received over 290
million dollars in scholarships with
many attending gcu for less than the
cost of a state university find your
purpose at gcu private christian
affordable visit gcu.edu
my offer to see what scholarships you
can apply for and qualify for go again
to gcu.edu my offer to find out more
great university great student body
terrific campus go check it out great
values which is the most important thing
check them out right now gcu.edu
my offer okay fine so all of this is
having a pretty dire effect on joe
biden's approval rating
because again
easy to be a house plant we're not doing
anything
when you're
as i mentioned the elderly gentleman who
should have had his license revoked 10
years ago driving a car directly into a
crowd
this uh this is a lot less charming you
can see it reflected in the approval
ratings so according to a new npr poll
joe biden's net approval rating is down
there is a new poll from npr pbs
newshour in marist it shows that his
approval rating is all the way down to
43.
so remember donald trump was widely
considered one of the most unpopular
presidents while he was president in
american history joe biden is now at
those levels joe biden is down in the
low 40s the problem is joe biden ain't
got a basement okay so so donald trump
had a floor his floor was a solid 40 no
matter what he did he was never going
below 40
and probably no matter what he did he
was never going above about 48
joe biden has no ceiling and he has no
floor right so joe biden could be 60
approval 70 approval
because there are times when he when he
has been
or he could be 25 approval because no
one loves joe biden
people merely tolerate the existence of
joe biden he is a stand-in he was only
voted for because he was running against
donald trump the only person that joe
biden could probably beat was donald
trump because he has never run a
successful campaign for anything other
than senator of a very small state he's
run for president 83 times he lost all
83 times the only reason he's a famous
person is because he was plucked from
relative obscurity by young barack obama
who needed an elderly white man to
accompany him on the ticket
he said now joe biden is president of
the united states and nobody is a joe
biden fan no one is out there being like
this guy is a great thinker he's a great
speaker he has great ideas
everybody's just kind of watching
him
toddle over to the
to the lunch counter at denny's and
they're like that guy
all right let's let's see what he does
but when he does bad stuff that means
that his approval rating is going to
continue to crater and chances are that
if things continue to go poorly for
biden it will get worse so he could now
be in a cycle right he could now be
taking a nosedive because on the
domestic front his basic idea was okay
well we'll bring all the troops home
i'll get a big boost from that and then
because i get a big boost from ending
the afghan war which was a big issue now
here's the thing he misread the room it
was not a big issue for anybody in
america
democrats think that because in their
cocktail parties they themselves spend a
lot of time talking about how the afghan
war is america's endless war americans
may agree that we should get out of
afghanistan but that is not a top 175
priority for americans americans
generally only care about foreign policy
when their serious loss is attached
if you're just like if you ask americans
right now what are your opinions on
troop levels in south korea americans
may have an opinion on that maybe in
fact they want some of the troops
removed from south korea is that
anything that has crossed their mind in
the last 25 years probably not the same
thing was true about afghanistan it had
become another one of just america's
protracted conflict where we had troops
on the ground and where we weren't
suffering serious casualties and serious
losses
joe biden made it a top priority and he
misinterpreted because he thought that
by doing this he would be garnering some
sort of public support and earning
political capital he could then expend
at home the problem is he actually lost
political capital and now he's running a
political capital deficit and he has no
place to borrow from the bank is closed
according to that poll 71 percent of u.s
citizens deem the u.s role in
afghanistan a failure 61 percent
disapprove of the president's handling
of the withdrawal 56 disapprove of his
foreign policy as a whole
those are brutal ratings the president's
approval rating dropped by six
percentage points from mary's august
poll in which biden earned a rating of
his support from democrats has dropped
by five points by 10 among independents
his approval rating has also dropped
since july's approval rating of fifty
percent
his net approval rating was plus five in
august plus seven in july he is now at
minus eight
since the us withdrawal from afghanistan
biden has lost the support of the
majority of independents a key voting
group biden won in 2020
so that is a that is a disaster area for
joe biden
meanwhile in polls that are even worse
for him
there's a poll out from abc news and it
shows that a huge percentage of
americans now believe we are less safe
okay so americans believe many things
simultaneously some of which conflict
with each other so for example a
majority of americans believe it is good
to get out of afghanistan but then a
huge majority of americans also believe
that we are now less safe because we got
out of afghanistan
now maybe that's a risk they're willing
to take i highly doubt it i think that
americans only respond to the question
that is put in front of them this is one
of the problems with polling
it is also true that when people answer
polls
yeah it's true in every social science
study social science studies demonstrate
that the worst kind of social science
study is when people do a
self-assessment
this is why for example there was
polling recently on how many people had
taken the vaccine the and went racial
group by racial group and it said in the
poll that a huge number of black
americans had taken the vaccine well the
cdc has actually measured who has taken
the vaccine by race and it turns out
that black americans are far less likely
to have taken the vaccine very often
people self-assess in self-flattering
ways this also happens with regard to
foreign policy so if you ask people do
you think that we are less safe now that
we're out of afghanistan people will say
yes and if you ask them also should we
have gotten out of afghanistan they
might also say yes
there's no obligation for them to be
ideologically consistent consistency
being the hobgoblin of little minds
only 36 percent of americans say the war
was worth fighting there were 77 percent
who support america withdrawing but 60
of americans disapprove of the way that
joe biden actually handled this thing
now
the most
i think important thing here is that
when asked exactly whether they feel it
safer because of job which is the
question for presidents right it is not
whether they think that what he did is
quote unquote right or wrong 44 of
americans think the withdrawal left the
united states left less safe from
terrorism
eight percent think the country is safer
as a result
and that that's
pretty shocking right
44 to 8 44 of americans think that us
withdrawing
means that we are now safe
eight percent think we are safer all of
those are immediate members of joe
biden's family and tony blanken's family
the rest see no difference which means
they don't care about the issue because
if you care about the issue it's pretty
obvious we're not as safe as we were
when we had those troops on the ground
and the taliban hadn't just provided a
new terror safe haven okay so what does
this mean it means again joe biden has
no leverage over his own membership none
which means that joe biden could be in
some serious trouble here which is why
yesterday jonathan chait was writing
angrily
about how
joe joe biden's presidency might be
ended by joe manchin why well joe
manchin put out an op-ed in the wall
street journal yesterday titled why i
won't support spending another 3.5
trillion dollars he says the nation
faces an unprecedented array of
challenges and will inevitably encounter
additional crises in the future yet some
in congress have a strange belief
there's an infinite supply of money to
deal with any current or future crisis
and that spending trillions upon
trillions will have no negative
consequence for the future i disagree an
overheating economy has imposed a costly
quote-unquote inflation tax
on every middle and working class
american at 28.7 trillion dollars in
growing the nation's debt has reached
record levels
and by the way it is amazing what the
levels of national debt were going back
historically
i mean i remember when george w bush was
blowing out the national debt and
everybody was freaking out about it and
this is back in
you know 2000 2003 we were spending tons
and tons of money
the federal debt held by the public as a
percentage of gdp
in like 2003 2004 was about 30 35
today the u.s national debt as a
percentage of the federal gdp
is approaching
it's well over 80 now it's approaching
90 or 100
it's a these are shocking statistics
obviously and if you look at kind of the
150 year view of the us national debt
you can see that we are now up to
actually 98.2
of gdp
right which is pretty unbelievable
because of the amount of massive
spending that we did last year and that
we were about to do now so we are we are
entering
really dangerous territory in terms of
the national debt
now people on the left don't care
because they think we can just print
money forever here's the reality about
about what you are doing when you
continue to sell debt which is basically
what you have to do and inflate the
currency in the process there's only a
few ways out of this one is you pay
people back with inflated currency you
actually start digitally generating
dollars and then handing those dollars
to bondholders the second is that you
just radically raise taxes on people
including middle-class people there just
are not enough tax dollars at the top of
the income spectrum the united states
has one of those progressive tax systems
on planet earth people on the top one
percent are paying a huge percentage of
the taxes people in the top half are
paying all of the taxes people in the
top 10 percent of income earners in the
united states are paying all met taxes
meaning they get no government benefits
and they're paying all the taxes
so you can't tax those people much more
so if you really want to spend the money
that we're spending right now you really
have to broaden the tax base which of
course is going to hamper economic
growth
okay so you can theoretically inflate
the currency you can theoretically raise
your taxes or you can get into a
situation where you are defaulting now
the united states is basically hoping
that we're still the best relative bet
compared to the rest of the market but
this is also why the united states is
not going to be in the future in favor
of a lot of economic innovation like
bitcoin being used as an alternative
currency because it debases the united
states currency and makes it less likely
that americans are going to invest their
money in things like bonds they're
afraid that they're going to be paid
back with inflated dollars so why would
i want to be paid back in inflated
dollars why would that be something
worthwhile okay all of this is we are
cruising for a financial bruising i
guess the story here and joe manchin is
correct about this
he says
over the past 18 months we've spent more
than five trillion dollars responding to
the crown virus pandemic now democratic
congressional leaders propose to pass
the largest single spending bill in
history with no regard to rising
inflation crippling debt or the
inevitability of future crises ignoring
the fiscal consequences of our policy
choices will create a disastrous future
for the next generation of americans
those who believe such concerns are
overstated should ask themselves what do
we do if the pandemic gets worse under
the next viral mutation what do we do if
there's a financial crisis like the one
that led to the great recession what if
we face a terrorist attack or major
international conflict how will america
respond to such crises if we needlessly
spend trillions of dollars today this is
right i mean obviously if you're going
to fire financial bullets at crisis you
should wait for an actual crisis
we are now at the tail end of the
pandemic there's a study came out today
it says probably upwards of 80 percent
of americans have some form of immunity
to covet whether it's natural immunity
or vaccine immunity
so what exactly are we talking about
spending five trillion dollars for right
now
says joe manchin again because he is a
senator from west virginia and not a
senator from new york instead of rushing
to spend trillions on new government
programs and additional stimulus funding
congress should hit a strategic pause on
the budget reconciliation legislation
a pause is warranted because it will
provide more clarity on the trajectory
of the pandemic it will allow us to
determine whether inflation is
transitory or not while some of us have
suggested this reconciliation
legislation must be passed now i believe
making budgetary decisions under
artificial political deadlines doesn't
lead to good policy or sound decisions
i've always said if i can't explain it i
can't vote for it i cannot explain why
my democratic colleagues are rushing to
spend 3.5 trillion dollars
also we must allow for complete
reporting and analysis of the
implications a multi-trillion dollar
bill will have for this generation and
the next
such a strategic pause says joe manchin
will allow every member of congress to
use the transparent committee process to
debate what should be fun what can we
simply not afford he says i for one
won't support a 3.5 trillion bill or
anywhere near that level of additional
spending without greater clarity about
why congress chooses to ignore the
serious effects inflation and debt have
on existing government programs this is
even more important now as social
security and medicare trustees have
sounded the alarm that these life-saving
programs will be insolvent and benefits
could be reduced as soon as 2026 for
medicare in 2033 a year earlier than
previously projected for social security
establishing an artificial 3.5 trillion
dollar spending number and reverse
engineering the partisan social
priorities that should be funded isn't
how you make good policy
undoubtedly some will argue bold social
policy actions should be taken now says
mansion while i share the belief we
should help those who need it most we
must also be honest about the prison the
present economic reality inflation is
rising it is bleeding the value of
americans wages and income more than 10
million jobs remain open our economy has
reached record levels of quarterly
growth this positive economic reality
makes clear the purpose of the 3.5
trillion dollars in new spending is not
to solve urgent problems but to
re-envision america's social policies
while my fellow democrats will disagree
i believe spending trillions more
dollars not only ignores president
economic reality but makes it certain
america will be fiscally weakened when
it faces a future recession or national
emergency
it says many in washington have
convinced themselves we can add
trillions of dollars more to our nearly
29 trillion national debt with no
repercussions regardless of political
party elected leaders are sent to
washington to make tough decisions and
not simply go along to get along
for those who dismiss my unwillingness
to support a 3.5 trillion bill as
political posturing i hope they heed the
powerful words of admiral mike mullen
former chairman of the joint chiefs who
calls debt the biggest threat to
national security
so mansion is basically saying that joe
biden needs to wait well if this thing
waits
do you think the conditions are going to
get riper for people to vote for a 3.5
trillion bill this thing needs to happen
now everybody knows that it needs to
happen now this is why democrats are
freaking out this is why jonathan chait
has a piece titled joe manchin has put
biden's presidency in mortal danger
he says the mercurial senator calls for
a pause when democrats desperately need
to move fast
he says this is the most bearish
indicator for biden
he says mansion's rationale for
demanding a pause is farcical et cetera
et cetera et cetera
and it's really bad and it's super
terrible
but he says the compromise negotiated in
the house requires an expedited schedule
with an infrastructure vote by the end
of the month the sequence is still
workable because all of the factions
have an understanding of what they'll
include in the social spending bill
without that understanding in place
progressives have every incentive to
vote down the infrastructure bill which
will in turn contribute to the
impression of dysfunction in chaos so in
other words there's a deal in place the
deal basically was that joe manchin and
cinema would vote for the infrastructure
bill and then nancy pelosi would
immediately ram through a reconciliation
bill manchin is now saying hit pause so
that means the timeline just got blown
up
this is what jonathan chad is pointing
out he says the sequence of mansions
negotiations is especially likely to
provoke distrust
he helped create a demand for a fast
infrastructure vote which necessitates
the scramble to speed up the second bill
indeed the most reasonable demand house
moderates have is to not be forced to
vote for a larger bill than mansion
ultimately agreed to
his insistence on waiting freezes
everything in place the danger is this
pause sets off a cycle of failure
wealthy interests are belatedly
mobilizing against the bill now the
democrats best chance is to move as fast
as possible delay creates the impression
of dysfunction making biden and congress
less popular in turn reducing the
popularity of any bill they pass in turn
making congress more reluctant to
support it joe biden has no coattails he
can't force this thing through this is a
serious problem for the democratic party
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first
let us talk about the fact that the
unknown came in 2020 it changed the
workplace forever some of us are getting
back to the office some of us are
finding themselves in a new normal at
home the future of work has changed so
has the future of the chair you must sit
on the x-chair let me tell you about the
x-chair this thing is like sitting on a
little slice of heaven ex-chair's newest
innovation lmx temperature regulation
will take your seating comfort to a
whole new level patent pending lmax
allows you to experience cooling heat
and massage in your low back if you're
feeling a bit warm in the summer you can
set your elements to cooling the air
conditioning in your home or office is
cranked up too high set your lmx to
heating warm up and soothe tired muscles
if you're feeling stressed from too many
zoom calls turn on lmx massage therapy
and relax
next chair's patented dynamic variable
lumbar support was already best in class
with incredible responsive low back
support now with lmx your comfort is
guaranteed imagine regulating your body
temperature and getting massage therapy
while you're working like i say it's
like you're being massaged by angels
while you sit and do your spreadsheets x
chair lms delivers cooling heat massage
technology directly to your core it
increases blood flow muscle recovery and
energy that makes working from home or
the office a joy so head on over to
xchairshapiro.com right now to get
started that's the letter x chair
s-h-a-p-i-r-o dot com or call 1-844-4x
chair for 100 bucks off your order
that's 1-844 for x-chair extra has a
30-day guarantee of complete comfort you
can finance your purchase for as little
as 30 bucks a month go to
xchairshapiro.com right now use codex
wheels for free xwheel bladecasters
xchairshapiro.com
to get started
alrighty let me remind you once a month
the hosts of the daily weather come
together backstage for some
light-hearted debate to dissect the
trending political and cultural topics
of the moment i'm telling you
october's gonna be a little different
and awesome instead of just tuning in
from your home you'll be able to see us
live and on stage at the famous ryman
auditorium in nashville doing what we do
best making sense so join me candace
owens jeremy boring michael knowles matt
walsh and andrew clavin for a backstage
like never before
so we had pre-sale tickets they sold out
literally within an hour yesterday
we have general admission tickets those
went on sale at 10 am today we are
offering three kinds of tickets vip
tickets those come with an exclusive
gift at a meet and greet with us
followed by a ticket that comes with
upgraded seating and a show poster and
finally we've got general seating
tickets whichever ticket you choose
i personally guarantee it's going to be
an awesome time hurry head on over to
dailywire.com ryman to purchase your
tickets before they sell out also this
sunday
we have a special episode of the sunday
special obviously next week marks
september 11th the 20th anniversary
thereof we are leaving afghanistan in
ignominious defeat handing the country
back to the very people who helped
perform 9 11. joining us to discuss all
of that is consolisa wright she's
national security adviser on 9 11 and
then secretary of state under george w
bush it's a fascinating and sobering
conversation here's a sneak peek
we were on afghan territory fighting the
counter-terrorism fight alongside
afghans alongside allies from nato
using intelligence assets that we had
developed to find bin laden and kill him
in pakistan
that 20 years bought us
a piece that i did not think possible
on september 12th
[Music]
be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com apple tv roku apps or on
my youtube channel ben shapiro again i
think it's a really important episode
it's something you're going to want to
share with friends and family if you
remember at 9 11 and particularly if you
know people who don't it's a must watch
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so in breaking news by the way
the august jobs report is out complete
fail complete absolute utter failure
which of course is not surprising
because we are paying people to stay
home and then we're talking about
inflating more we're talking about more
stimulus we're talking about by the way
telling people that they must stay home
because of the pandemic when that is
obviously not true if you're vaccinated
you should not be afraid of other people
who are unvaccinated because you're
vaccinated it's the whole damned point
of getting vaccinated in the first place
so
the reality there's a reason why these
states that are doing best in terms of
the
unemployment rate are all red states and
the states that are all doing the worst
are the blue states there's a reason for
that the august jobs report how bad was
it
economists had forecasted 725 000 jobs
being created remember there are 10
million open jobs in the united states
right now
725 000 jobs is what the economists have
been forecasting the actual number of
jobs created
was 235 000 jobs they were off by a
factor of three they're off by a factor
of three
that is a disaster area for the biden
administration and again they keep
missing the mark they keep missing it
over and over they'll have like one good
month and then they'll have three
terrible months
that is because you have completely
destroyed all of the incentive
structures causing people to go back to
work you've destroyed supply lines
you're artificially boosting demand by
pouring money into people's pockets but
you can tell by the way that that sort
of inflation is not actual price
inflation it's not sort of heated it's
not economic heating you know how you
know because if you look at the loan
numbers like whether people are actually
taking out loans the answer is no people
are not taking out loans under these
circumstances because they're afraid
they're not going to be able to pay them
back
and that is because the underlying
fundamentals that are being created by
the regulate and spend and tax biden
economy are a lot weaker than the
fundamentals of an economy that was much
more laissez faire under donald trump
this is this is wild i mean so
the fed is now saying that the august
jobs of course was a failure
but because of that they're going to
keep buying assets did ever occur to
them that the reason the jobs reports a
failure is because you keep inflating
the currency is because you keep paying
people to stay home it's because of
unemployment benefits it's because
you're creating
enormous pressure for businesses to
spend more money than they are actually
taking in on employees
like this is all causing inflation of
course and um but they're saying it's
transitory which is fine
terrible news for the economy not a
shock the unemployment rate fell to 5.2
in august from 5.4
before according to the bureau of labor
statistics
there's a reason why bitcoin by the way
just rose past 50 000 per bitcoin
the reason for that is because people
are now investing in some form of more
solid asset than the united states
dollar given what the federal government
is doing right now
by the way
uh according to the the economic report
there were job losses in certain sectors
in the retail sector almost 30 000 jobs
lost in the restaurant sector 42 000
jobs lost
and there were 36 000 jobs picked up in
the entertainment sector that's probably
going to take a nosedive considering
that joe biden continues to shut down
the economy that's amazing what the
people in in the media they're going to
attribute this to the delta spike
the reality is that the only reason that
you are seeing shutdowns right now and
tremendous fear right now is because the
media have made it seem as though even
if you are vaccinated you should be
afraid this goes back to a point i was
making yesterday about covet which
really is the salient point if you had
to draw a chart of the worried and the
unworried when it comes to
when it comes to covet i'm actually
gonna do it for you right now okay here
we have a circle it's the worried here
we have a circle it is the unworried
okay
these are the two circles of the
american population
okay the unworried contain some people
who are vaccine who are vaccinated right
i'm unworried and i'm vaccinated so some
part of this circle
are the vaccinated okay but the rest of
this circle are the unvaxed the entirety
of the people who are unvaxed are
unworried i say that because if they
were worried they would go get faxed it
is the best solution to your worry is to
get faxed okay but then if you look at
the circle of the word
they're the entire circle
the entire circle is vaccinated of the
worried okay the entirety of the circle
is vaccinated
so right now you have the biden
administration basically
telling the vaccinated to shut down the
economy worry about the vaccinated worry
worry worry worried
okay but those are the people who
shouldn't be worried
we're now at the point where if you are
a sentient adult in the united states
and you don't have some unbelievably
severe pre-existing condition in which
your doctor says you shouldn't get a
vaccine
you have the option to do whatever the
hell you want
if the economy is shutting down it's
because of joe biden joe biden's
credibility is shredded he said he's
going to stop the virus he has not he
said that he wasn't going to kill the
economy he has he said that he was going
to shore up our credibility onto on the
international stage not only has he not
done that he's destroyed our credibility
on the international stage
and now all the big hopes that he had
for restructuring the nature of american
government they ride
on joe manchin and christian cinema
and this is an unsuccessful failed
presidency and we are not even a year in
that house plans is beginning to wilt in
serious fashion all right we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content first you cannot forget to
end your week by checking out the andrew
clavin show drew's shows every friday
he's got an exciting evening planned for
you head on over to dailywire.com at 7
pm eastern 6 pm central tune in i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin
[Music]